hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel for anyone who doesn't know
me and solely because it is relevant to
what we're going to be talking about in
this video I've been working in the
games industry for just under a decade I
worked for GN full-time for three years
reviewed a lot of games from them for
them and started out in print magazines
and it worked through a bunch of
different websites including many of the
major ones whose names you know
basically I feel like I have the
experience to talk about what I'm
talking about today for any of you who
have no idea who I am
moving on this is gonna be kind of a
tough video because there are certain
topics that especially when you work in
games media are really hard to talk
about to give you a very good example
I played Mass Effect Andromeda long
before it came out the whole world was
very excited about Mass Effect Andromeda
and I played it for about three hours
and I walked out of the room and was
crushed because I had the thought oh no
it's bad I can't lie in good conscience
and tell the Internet that it's good but
because they want to hear that it's good
when I say it's bad they're going to
[ __ ] hate me therein lies a
complicated issue with covering any kind
of fan media as your job in any critical
way saying that I thought Mass Effect
Andromeda was going to be bad
again at a point in time where it seemed
like the whole world thought it was
going to be good mentha and I did get a
lot of [ __ ] on the internet for a long
time but point being I knew people
didn't want to hear it just like I know
people don't really want to hear what
I'm saying in this video and it would be
a lot easier for me to tell you that
games journalists are corrupt and paid
off because that's what you want to hear
that would get me a lot of positive
comments and it would get me a lot of
subscribers and it would be shared it
would get a lot of views that is the
thing that would put me in good favor
with the Internet and I am aware of that
but that is not the truth there is
nuance to that and I'm gonna get into it
here I'm gonna talk about my genuine
experiences touched on this in other
videos and bunch of facets of this in
other videos but this is just one video
about this one thing so I'm just gonna
ask you the Internet I mean
it's not gonna work but I'm gonna try to
keep in mind that it is difficult for
people like me to talk about this topic
honestly because you may not want to
hear it but honesty should I feel like
be the thing that we want the most I
feel like we can all agree on that I
don't feel like either side of this the
media side or the public side always do
a good job of executing on that so I'm
just gonna ask you try to watch this
video with an open mind that's it I am
trying to give you an inside perspective
I'm not trying to reinforce things that
aren't true because frankly it would
benefit me way more if I lied so first
thing that I want to talk about is not
directly related to that and to a lot of
you might seem obvious but is a thing
that I noticed that the internet gets
confused about all the time that is come
up this week specifically the loss of is
part two is getting a lot of 10 out of
10 review scores I do not personally
agree with these scores frankly I would
not have given the last of his part to a
10 out of 10 however that doesn't make
me any more correct than the people who
do believe it is a 10 out of 10 and I
genuinely do believe that they think
that the one note that keeps being
brought up to me is people saying well
it has flaws how can it be a 10 out of
10 which is where I pull up the IGN as
most people's go to god this chest
taking up so much screen so if I Jan as
most people's go-to for schools they do
get the most traffic on their reviews
historically and obviously I can talk
about IGN as I worked there as a
full-time employee let's talk about the
IGN review scale a 10 out of 10 is not
perfect that's that's that's really it a
lot of you again probably already know
this point but I want to jump to it off
the bat 10 out of 10 does not mean a
game was perfect nothing is perfect on
IGN scale a 10 is listed as a
masterpiece and I generally agree with
that a 10 should be very difficult to
get and I do believe there are pieces of
IGN's pause where they gave out tens way
too readily but I digress 10 out of 10
is not a perfect game on a directly
related point 5 is not average I think
that audience is like who put so much
weight in review scores which by the way
is why these major websites still have
review scores people complain about the
schools all the time
comments sections people are always
talking about them they can
shares the more audience puts weight on
scores the more it reinforces to these
websites that they need to have scores
because their audiences clearly really
care about them and they get traffic
from them so five is mediocre
that does not mean average the reason
that you get so many game review schools
that are around the seven range is
because frankly most of the games that
these major sites are reviewing all
major magazines or whatever are
reviewing are really [ __ ] good if you
only play triple-a games which let's be
honest most gamers do then you only see
the games that are getting eights nines
and tens because they are usually
extremely high quality
I mean fallout 76 and crackdown 3
apparently both got a 5 so that's worth
noting
those are triple-a but it doesn't mean
that there are no games that full will
be below 5 games come out every single
day that would be considered bad or
unplayable or broken but IGN isn't going
to waste most of its time reviewing all
of those games because it's impossible
but B audiences don't generally even
care about those games that's the shovel
where that shows up on the Nintendo
switch shop that's half of the junk that
shows up on Steam so yes loads and loads
and loads of bad games exist you just
don't see them reviewed because nobody
is even going to pay attention to those
reviews for the most part tan is not
perfect 5 is not average 5 is mediocre a
7 or an 8 probably is the average
aggregate score because majority of the
games that are being reviewed simply are
good and I feel like that covers a whole
lot of the conversation and the
discourse that I've seen surrounding the
last of us part 2 what people have said
well this review even lists flaws how is
it a 10 out of 10 it is still considered
a masterpiece by that reviewing that is
that's the case another thing that I
want to talk about is Metacritic because
this is the thing that people also don't
know
Metacritic doesn't actually accurately
just aggregate skulls there are a couple
of games that play where Metacritic is
concerned for one there are a number of
negative reviews of the Last of Us Part
2 that are unscored we click here
polygons review is unscored and says
part 2 ends up feeling needlessly bleak
at a time when a nihilistic worldview
has
perhaps never been less attractive the
Vice is also negative the loss of his
part to feels complacent yet also
preoccupied with its predecessor every
facet of the original game has been
expanded on and enlarged in the sequel
but not actually improved Kotaku same
thing none of those accomplishments
elevated or redeemed it for me like the
nature consuming Seattle or the outbreak
consuming a few consuming humanity its
ugliness overshadowed everything else
these don't have scores I would say that
probably more likely to be mixed than
they ought to be inherently negative but
what Metacritic will often do is try to
score the unscored reviews itself they
will kind of guess and then add a score
and maybe they'll do that eventually for
these ones that are currently unscored
but they do do that they also weight
different outlets review schools
differently so like IGN because it is
the Guardian would be one as well Game
Informer because they are considered
reputable outlets they get a higher
weight than other websites that
metacritic might not be familiar with do
so that is also a thing that is worth
noticing you're putting way too much
stock into Metacritic is basically my
point it is also a very subjective
outlet in a lot of ways obviously the
public continues to have this idea that
reviews are paid off or that reviewers
are giving the last of his part to a ten
out of ten because they don't want to be
blacklisted from getting more of you
copies from Sony the only time that I
have ever heard of Sony being annoyed at
an outlet where review copies was
concerned was when they broke in bother
and outlet agreed to not talk about a
certain thing or do something and the
outlet did it you are not giving the
last of us a 10 out of 10 so Sony will
give you more review copies they
wouldn't do it
and the truth is if that's a thing that
you're worried about I think that you
should be getting angry at Sony and Sony
PR and the embargoes that they did put
on the last of his part to that prevent
people from talking about a lot of the
second half of the game but I also 100%
believe that this is this dude's opinion
this is how Jonathan feels about this
game knowing this guy personally I am
positive that he at no point thought I
better give this game a 10 so IGN can
get more reviews because writers are a
bunch of
pretentious idiots myself included who
care so much more about their own
integrity and how their peers view their
integrity than they care about
publishers quickly jumping back in here
on this note because I feel like I
phrased what I said Paulie initially
this is my biggest criticism of games
journalism is that I do think in a lot
of cases writers write things for their
peers rather than for the audience while
that still means that being honest it
does mean that we have all of these
reviewers who in the case of the lost of
us are buying into Hayat because they're
very passionate about the games industry
and very passionate about storytelling
in videogames that is their perspective
but it is also not necessarily the
perspective that you know that most
people who are going to read your review
are going to share that is a complicated
topic as well but yes my number one
criticism of games media is that I think
that a lot of journalists write things
for their Twitter followers who also
work in the industry more so than they
do for the people who read their website
back to the original video but also very
important note when I published the
negative piece about Mass Effect
Andromeda you know what I was scared of
genuinely the public I didn't even think
about EA at no point did I think oh no
EA is going to be mad at me if I tear
this game apart I don't care I can also
bet you that every outlet that gave this
a 10 out of 10 and no part was like
Sony's gonna love us they were probably
more like oh my god the internet is
going to [ __ ] hate me but I have to
stick to my guns herein lies the problem
and the thing that I would ask of you
the internet if you have opinions on
review scores and that someone gives
something a score that doesn't align
with what you think but at the same time
you're a person who wants writers to be
honest you kind of have to stop
harassing those writers every time they
write something that you personally
don't agree with again I know you don't
want to hear this I know that you would
like this video more if I told you that
I jeans reviews were paid off which dear
God would every journalist at that
website ever have leaked it Dan
Stapleton is not the kind of man who's
ever gonna [ __ ] take I never had
anyone while I was there told me to
change a review score they just asked
what I thought then I was never swayed
not even
one time so if you complain about ethics
and games journalism oh you want your
riders to be honest you've caught at the
same time harass them when they give a
school that you don't like hearing you
know that conflicts with itself in a way
that seems very obvious to me because
again I promise you right is a so much
more scared of the public than they are
of publishers and I guess it's just so
weird from the writers perspective or
from my perspective even as someone who
doesn't really give review schools
anymore I try to stay away from all that
[ __ ] because I can now I hope to never
do it again to have people complain
about ethics and honesty in review
scores but have them also yell when the
review schools aren't the ones that they
want to read there are absolutely things
that happen in each of these major
websites that I think I was looking at
critically I think IGN first is a bit
Shady
that is a thing where IGN gets very
early access to games as like a cover
story game in FOMA style to do a bunch
of previews previews all largely
positive because you only really see the
part of the game that the dev knows is
going to be seen positively but that
exchange of access does mean it would be
very complicated for the ongoing
relationship of that month of IGN first
or whatever it is if you did say
anything negative I always feel like I
was honest in every idea and first that
I did it was maybe two or three but it
is hard to say that there wouldn't be
some unconscious bias there that could
potentially exist interpersonal
relationships totally can be a concern I
am NOT reviewing the last of his part to
you because I'm Prince of Troy Baker I
don't want to do it it would be weird
while I absolutely don't think that my
relationship with Troy would in any way
influence the way that I would review a
game I don't even want the public to
have the ability to have that perception
I don't want to take a chance on that
subconscious bias you know so I'm just
not doing it relationships between
writers and publishers and developers
can be issues review is getting paid off
not an issue review is giving games a
ten out of ten because they care about a
publisher not an issue it may be be
worried if they gave the loss of his
part to a six and if it is an issue I
think the public should be getting mad
at the publishers for restricting access
to journalists who are trying to give
you the best idea of what a product is
in their opinion so that you can make an
informed
purchasing this region they are on your
side on to my third point which I will
talk about on my podcast that goes up on
Fridays play watch listen which is with
Mike Biffle who is a game director
Austin Wintory who is a game composer
and Troy Baker obviously video game act
up all of those people worked in the
industry for a long time I'm gonna have
them talk more about this but I can
touch on it game reviews do not
contribute to sales in the way that the
public seems to think they do frankly
the like upset that spots around game
reviews is a little bit weird because of
how truly unimportant they are in the
grand scheme of things they don't
[ __ ] matter yes there are people who
will tell you that they made a purchase
based on a review those people exist but
the statistics show that in large part
game reviews do not influence sales
frankly press coverage in general
doesn't influence sales myself and Tom
marks I believe worked together to write
one of the first pieces about how bad
Star Wars Battlefront 2 was initially in
terms of microtransactions in the
multiplayer the internet seemed furious
they seemed so mad when that all came
out took EA a few days and then they
took them out but they came back and
from the internet rhetoric around that
you would think that that game wasn't
going to sell well it's all great didn't
[ __ ] matter didn't matter at all
statistics have also shown if you look
up the news stories you'll find them
that the leaks haven't influenced
pre-orders for the Last of Us in any
significant way you'd think that they
had because when you're like very
involved in games culture it feels like
the most important thing in the world
they haven't it pre-ordered better than
spider-man which is one of the best
selling games on the platform of all
time and those pre-orders all happen
before the reviews even go up reviews
are just absolutely not as important to
sales as I think the public thinks they
are and like I said I will have people
who actually work in the industry and
actually have had a lot of stake in
games being sold talk about that later
this week because I I while I have read
up a lot about it and can tell you
anecdotal experiences I've not sold a
video game so I don't feel like I should
make a big point of talking about that
so yeah try not to get too mad at me of
course I am on the inside I only have an
inside perspective back before I worked
in the games industry I was convinced
game reviews were paid off too and then
I worked in the industry and I realized
how dumb that was and it is really
le just that people have different
patience if you know that someone can
like chocolate cake and another person
can hate chocolate cake it should make
sense to you that someone can love the
lost of his part too and someone can
hate the lost of his part too they're
just a mass of different opinions I
promise
so in conclusion one ten out of ten
review score does not mean perfect and a
five does not mean average two writers
are a lot more afraid of you than they
are of publishers and I would say most
of them don't even think of publishers
if they do they shouldn't be [ __ ]
working in the industry three review
scores do not matter anywhere near as
much as you think they do I hope that I
have explained my perspective here
thoroughly please don't be too mad at me
I'm not trying to condescend or do
anything like that this is just a really
loaded topic to talk about the people
have very strong opinions on and I am
just trying to share a perspective that
again I know this video would be more
successful and I would get more
subscribers and it would be shared on
reddit and it would be broken out into
new stories and I would get a ton of
views and make money if I told you that
review schools are paid off but it is
simply not the truth it is an easier
thing for me to say but it is simply not
the truth I do recognize that there are
some ethical things that can influence
review schools because humans are humans
there is no perfect way to do it but I
don't think giving the lost of his part
to a ten out of ten means you're a Sony
shill
I wouldn't have given it a 10 and I
still know that this is just actually
what Jonathan thinks okay I'm very
nervous publish this one but we're gonna
do it cuz it feels like the right thing
to do
oh boy I am also gonna have a spoiler
cost of loss was puck to up later this
week where I'm going to have myself
being in the 7/8 range to journalist who
gave it a five out of six in their heads
and another two who gave it a 10 and a
10 so I'm gonna have this like
journalist battle royale where you can
fully heal these people talk about the
different impassioned perspectives live
so that you like fully understand it I
feel like it's gonna be really fun if I
can actually pull it together without
those people killing each other
alrighty everyone I'm alone I'll see you
guys next time like